in the last video we saw an egg from our
mothers fused with a sperm from our
fathers to form a zygote that would keep
replicating and turn into us if this is
this lets let's say this was the sperm
from my father that fuses with the egg
from my mother and then this is I goat
will keep replicating and eventually
turn into Sal and make a video about
fertilization so how does that actually
happen so now that this zygote has the
diploid number of chromosomes and once
again they're referring to that as 2n
where n would be the haploid number 2 n
would be the diploid number and in the
case of human beings n is 23 so in the
case of human beings n is 23 and 2 times
n of course would be 46 chromosomes have
my full contingency of chromosomes here
I got a why sex chromosome from my
father X of course from my mother so I'm
going to be a male and so what then
happens
well now through mitosis this zygote is
going to keep replicating so it will you
know after 1 so after 1 and we're going
to go into the details of the mechanics
of mitosis but after one round of
mitosis it is now 2 cells it is now 2
cells and I'm going to draw it once
again I'm not going to draw it at scale
it's now 2 cells I want to make sure I
have enough space on my little
chalkboard here and it has 2 cells
instead of drawing all of the
chromosomes let me just say that each of
these chrome eat in my nucleus I still
have 2 n I have the diploid number so I
each of these 2 cells that it is
differentiated to still have the full
contingency that's what mitosis does it
essentially replicates the entire cells
you have the same number of chromosomes
and then this process is just going to
keep happening these two characters are
going to replicate are going to
replicate and so then you're going to
have through mitosis and now you're
going so this is another round of
mitosis right over here mitosis so they
just keep duplicating themselves and
each of these cells have the full have
the full contingency
to end the diploid number of chromosomes
for well in this case is going to be 46
for human being and then this process is
just going to keep happening so this
process is going to keep happening I'll
do dot dot dot to show that you know a
lot of this has been going on so mitosis
is just going to keep happening and so
eventually you're going to have
thousands of these cells and eventually
as we'll see you're going to have
millions and ten millions of them so let
me draw them really really really small
so there's a bunch of them there and and
each of them each of them are going to
have the diploid number of chromosomes
they're going to have 46 chromosomes 23
pair of homologous chromosomes so we now
have a big ball of these here and these
cells some of them are going to they're
going to differentiate into me they're
going to differentiate into the
different parts of my body so for
example these cells right over here
might eventually they'll keep
replicating and but then it's them and
their offspring might eventually
differentiate into my brain cells these
cells here will keep replicating and
they and them and their offspring I
guess you could say the things that they
replicate into might differentiate into
my heart these right over here might
differentiate into into my lungs and of
course you know all of these eventually
will differentiate into all of the
different all of the or and they and
their offspring will differentiate into
all of the things that make me me and so
you go you have a lot more of this
mitosis you're eventually going to have
you're eventually going to have a human
being so let me just say this is more
mitosis going on my ptosis and now let
me have make an attempt to draw to draw
a human being so that doesn't really
look like me but well I have a lot of
hair so that's my big eyebrows as well
well it still doesn't look like me but
anyway you get the point
and so and I'll try to draw him fairly
or fairly quickly
but this is obviously not my best
rendering of a human being but you get
the general idea nice broad shoulders
that's nice alright so let me let me I'm
focusing too much on drawing this human
being but anyway I give you get you get
the general idea I don't my stomach
isn't that quite that flat but anyway
you get the general idea
so this it'll eventually differentiate
into a human being
these cells here and pink eventually
differentiate into the cells in the in
the brain these cells here eventually
differentiate into the cells into the
lungs and obviously have this at this
scale the cells are way too small to
even see these cells differentiated into
the cells of the heart now I want to
draw an important distinction here
because most of the cells that I've just
depicted here that are just a product of
mitosis these are your I guess you could
say these are your body cells or these
are your somatic cells so these all of
these cells that I'm pointing out in
your heart your lung or brain these are
somatic cells or body cells somatic
cells and so you're probably wondering
well how do I eventually get these
haploid number cells how do I eventually
get if I'm talking about a male how do I
have intricate these haploid sex cells
these gametes these sperm cells I'm
talking about a female how do I
eventually get these OVA these egg cells
that have a haploid number and the way
that happens is some of these cells up
here are going to differentiate into
germ cells so they're going to
differentiate into germ cells in the
case in the case of and and they're
going to differentiate it whenever germ
cells they're going to differentiate
into your gonads in the case of a in the
case of a female the gonads are the
ovaries are the ovaries ovaries and in
the case of a male the gonads are the
testes the gonads are the testes and the
germ cells in the gonads that or that
are
or the sales that have differentiated
into the being part of the testes and
ovaries those germ cells so we
differentiate them in we differentiate
them from somatic cells so they're germ
cells they're germ cells in your ovaries
and testes they through the process of
meiosis they through the process of
meiosis can produce the gametes so if
you're a female they're going to produce
eggs if your feet if you're male you're
going to produce sperm but this is
through the process of meiosis meiosis
you're going to produce sperm in the
case of a man and you're going to
produce and you're going to produce OVA
in the case of a female and this brings
up a really interesting thing because
throughout biology we talk about
mutations and and a natural selection
and whatever else and it's important to
realize what mute what mutate how
mutations may affect you and your
offspring so if you have a mutation in
one of the somatic cells here let's say
in your in a skin cell or in your brain
or in the heart that may affect your
ability to you know especially if god
forbid it's a really dangerous thing
like cancer and it happens when you're
young before you've had a chance to
reproduce and you're not able to survive
that it might affect that might affect
your ability to reproduce but if this is
happening in a somatic cell it's not
going to affect the DNA makeup of what
you pass on the DNA makeup of what you
pass on that's determined by what's
going on in the gametes so mutation if
on the way to differentiating into
gametes a mutation happens so for if one
of these mutate and then keep
replicating so let's say there's a
mutation here and they keep replicating
and they differentiate into the germ
cells the mutation is right over there
and then through meiosis that produces
some mutated sperm then that would pass
on to your well that has a chance of
passing on to your children because once
again it might not be all of the sperm
cells that have that mutation it could
be only
handful of the two to three hundred
million of the sperm cells and so if
that mutation somehow makes it harder
for some of the sperm cells to kind of
function either fuse with an egg or even
potentially develop and kind of swim
through fluid then it still might not be
the thing that makes it so mutations
mutations only affect your offspring in
the situation where those the mutations
in the the cells in which they happen
are eventually differentiate into things
into gametes that you will pass on to
your children